I want to talk about Nia and brainy it's
happening things are moving things are
happening the key things are happening
the fandom is like in love with the
awkward interactions isn't that but it's
relatable right yeah but when the big
kiss when the big moment happened what
was it like for you shooting that did
you know that the reaction from the
fandom was gonna be so big no I mean I I
new folks are gonna be excited because
since Nia and brainy met in Episode two
um you know everybody was kind of well
not everybody but a lot of folks were
kind of like oh that would be cute and
then just as the season progressed folks
got more on board with it yeah and so
then when the kiss was gonna happen and
I was hearing all the hype around
episode 15 because of course it was Aziz
forcep so this Kelly and then James had
just been shot so there was a lot
happening in the episode anyway Jon
Cryer is Lex Luthor so everyone was just
kind of like it was already a lot of
hype around the episode and I was like
oh they're not ready um so it was really
fun how fun has it been to develop this
character she's kind of finding her legs
finding her figure out her powers what's
it like for you
I mean it's so it's really strange
because of course in the comics
Dreamgirls powers were pretty limited to
seeing the future yeah in her dreams and
exactly how unconscious she was varied
depending on the iteration and so now
especially with the gloves that Nia gets
from brainy the scope of her powers has
kind of exceeded that so you have like
drink blasts and astral projection so
every time they kind of they're like hey
so this is what dreamer doesn't like I
just I just have all the powers yeah
like someone get me a Legion ring once I
can fly that's it I don't need any more
superheroes ever different types writers
and you like uh you know what I think
boomer should have these powers and
these powers pretty much yeah pretty
much I'm just like hey guys how do we
feel about like invulnerable
yeah perfect now your dreamers a
trailblazing character and your
trailblazing
actor as well now the first transgender
superhero
how does it feel the reaction has been
so positive right it's oh my god
going into San Diego Comic Con where it
was announced and I was very very
nervous because that that's the kind of
thing that it can go either way
yeah um you know it could either be you
know like lots of a pause or crickets
mm-hmm um and so to see that outpouring
of love and support for both me and Mia
as a character was so heartwarming and I
was and it just made me like so
endlessly excited to get to bring me
into life and to get to kind of dislike
he said find her likes a streamer and
just to aside from being a trans
superhero just to have her be a really
cool superhero yeah one of the things I
think the fans love about the era versus
in general and Supergirl specifically is
the way it takes stories from real life
issues from real life and it corset and
incorporates them into the show and how
they treat them and greg has been very
vocal about how he wants to do that how
most have to be progressive are you
proud to be a part of a production like
that absolutely I mean my career kind of
stems out of activism so being able to
intersect the two you know for me is a
complete joy yeah so being able and you
know I think with a show that's about
aliens you know you wonder okay well
what would this look like in real life
and I think it would look a lot like how
we're showing it it would be met with
racism and xenophobia and bigotry and so
then it's also just really exciting from
a storytelling perspective because I
think from the last three seasons you
know they've kind of been doing villains
that you know you can you can punch yes
but you know I think this season you
know the big baddie is not necessarily
something we can fight it is well it's
not something you can fight with people
yeah
it's bigger than any one person it's
kind of like when Ben Lockwood was sent
to present who was like it doesn't
matter who agent Liberty is you know
it's the principle of the thing so you
know it's it's been really exciting to
get to sort of explore a new a new way
of fighting yeah
supervillains yeah now we're getting to
the end of the season
banjo anticipating a lot of things I
know you can't spoil anything you can't
tell absolutely if you could describe
the season finale in four words Oh God
four words how would you do it
four words
shoot I ramble for very big words more
big words big words possibly words that
sound like more than one word I would
say climactic first of all I would say
cliffhanger okay I would say I'm like
trying to like think of words that like
tell you something really great name
being like nope spoiler no boy no yeah
well that most I remember what happens
[Laughter]
let's see it's exciting yes um for a lot
of different characters and it's me if
this isn't this isn't one word but it's
mixed emotions okay
it is it is a happy ending for some and
and where does this leave us now for
others so it'll be like an emotional
roller coaster it is an emotional roller
coaster for the viewers there's a lot
happening yeah but it's cutting kind of
comes together okay at the end in your
hand cuz you know it's kind of we've had
not a bunch of different storylines but
we've this season we've had one
overarching storyline with a bunch of
kind of different villains yeah and this
in the finale all kind of comes together
and you see how it's all connected hmm
and you know it's kind of like how are
the Superfriends gonna how are the
Superfriends gonna overcome this and in
the short term and long term yeah
so will you say that the fans will be
satisfied I am very happy with the
finale excellent I can't wait it's gonna
be great